[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález el 2020 será
recordado por obvias razones por la
pandemia del cob y 19 y las múltiples
consecuencias que trabajo para la
humanidad este hecho que nos tomó por
sorpresa en diferentes aspectos pero
esto no impidió que el acontecer
siguiera su curso las noticias y también
los hechos destacados siguieron teniendo
lugar pese a que estábamos muy atentos a
la pandemia en este especial del debate
hablaremos de esos otros hechos que
fueron noticias durante el año 2020 en
brasil hemos hecho una selección de
cuatro temas que se los presento a
continuación en este programa hablaremos
entonces primero de un tema
medioambiental los incendios en la
región del pantanal y en la amazonía que
tanta polémica y reclamos les llevaron a
las autoridades brasileñas también
hablaremos del revés político que tuvo
el presidente ya ir bolsonaro y el
partido de los trabajadores el pp en los
resultados de las elecciones regionales
se quedaron sin varios alcaldes y sin
varios gobernadores de puntos
estratégicos de ese país
y también le daremos por supuesto una
mirada a la perspectiva económica para
el 2021 y algo de lo que sucedió en el
2020 y por supuesto comentaremos sobre
la gestión de la pandemia por parte del
presidente bolsonaro muchos la
criticaron otros la aceptaron como
siempre hay diferentes perspectivas en
torno a este tema pues para analizar y
conocer detalles sobre estos temas que
tenemos para la agenda de este programa
saludamos a johana amaya ella es
magíster en estudios latinoamericanos
doctora en gobierno y también es
profesora de la universidad de essex en
el reino unido- nos acompaña a esta hora
desde la ciudad de colchester allí en el
reino unido- en el norte de europa y
también está con nosotros gustavo segré
él es analista político internacional
socio del center group quien se
encuentra en la ciudad de sao paulo en
brasil les recuerdo que también ustedes
pueden hacer parte de esta conversación
pueden dejar también sus preguntas sus
comentarios en las redes sociales se la
recuerdo estamos en facebook y también
estamos en instagram y en twitter y nos
encuentran como france24
sant y luego que es mi cuenta personal
la etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
comienzo entonces con joana que era la
primera mitad que les estaba presentando
para este programa y nuestro tema de
inicio es el tema del medio ambiente
este año alrededor de una cuarta parte
del vasto humedal del pantanal en brasil
que es uno de los lugares más
biodiversos del planeta se ha quemado en
unos incendios forestales que le ha
generado todo tipo de críticas al
gobierno brasileño que tan comprometido
está brasil joana con las políticas
ambientales con proteger el pantanal con
proteger la amazonía y porque le han
llovido tantas críticas al gobierno
bueno indiscutiblemente el aumento de
los incendios en un 84 por ciento
respecto al 2019 registramos alrededor
de 72.843 incendios en el último año
pues esto muestra que el compromiso del
gobierno de wells ahora no para la
detención de estos incendios ha sido muy
baja esto ha hecho que la comunidad
internacional para el tercer sector las
ongs se movilicen y también actores
estatales directamente el presidente
macro y el primer ministro yo sin crudo
han llamado
bolsonaro al gobierno del sur a rendir
cuentas ya tocar este tema en la agenda
del g7 entonces esto está afectando no
sólo la política internacional y el
hecho de que consideramos el amazonas
como un patrimonio de la humanidad pero
también a las poblaciones locales y las
poblaciones indígenas
están siendo devastadas y afectadas por
estas deforestaciones masivas que
muestran una contraposición del modelo
del agronegocio que defiende bolsonaro y
el modelo de conservación que muchas
organizaciones locales y brasileras ongs
del tercer o tercer sector a nivel
internacional y gobiernos
internacionales defienden
gustavo pongo en perspectiva a nuestros
televidentes que tal vez no están muy
relacionados con la región del pantanal
y por qué es importante y relevante en
términos de medio ambiente tiene muchas
bondades para américa del sur porque
regula el ciclo del agua del que depende
la vida en nuestra región en nuestro
continente tiene incontables pantanos
lagunas afluentes que purifican el agua
y también ayudan a prevenir las
inundaciones y las sequías que son
problemas pues que estamos viviendo ya
con mayor frecuencia en la región
suramericana su opinión sobre el manejo
que le dio el gobierno brasileño a esta
crisis medioambiental que también
involucró a países vecinos a paraguay y
a bolivia que también se vieron
afectados por estos incendios
bueno buenas tardes para todos buenas
noches para ayudan a que está en otro
funcionario y usted es también diferente
de brasil el gobierno bolsonaro no actuó
con la energía que debería haberlo hecho
no obstante que cuando uno lo analiza en
la perspectiva correspondiente al tema
de la biomasa que se ha perdido en forma
lamentable y terrible sobre todo en el
pantanal donde fueron 21 mil focos más
de 21.000 focos es más del doble del año
anterior del año 2019 y esto se debió
básicamente a tres factores no a la
sequía que hacía mucho tiempo no se veía
no se observaba una sequía tan grande a
los focos intencionales que son fuegos
que los agropecuarias realizan para
mejorar en la tierra para poder cosechar
mejor y a las demoras en el combate y
ahí creo que sí fue una responsabilidad
no solamente el gobierno bolsonaro como
también de los gobiernos provinciales
inherentes a esa región fíjate voz
santiago y joana y la gente que nos
escucha es que el área para para tener
perspectiva de nuevo
devastada por los incendios en el
pantanal equivale a 19 veces la ciudad
de san pablo donde vivimos aquí 12
millones de personas y estamos hablando
de algo realmente enorme por el lado de
la amazonia ocurre algo parecido esto
que puede generar muchos problemas al
gobierno brasileño porque los acuerdos
de la unión europea y el mercosur corren
riesgos precisamente por la falta de
política ambiental y de sustentación del
medio ambiente del gobierno bolsonaro
pero no fue la peor época cuando uno
analiza el pasado de brasil en amazon es
como bien decía joana hubieron más de 89
mil focos de incendio en el año 1998
fueron 218 mil con el gobierno de la
época de fernando henrique cardoso y el
menor también en la época de fernando
henrique cardoso en el año 2000 que
generó 48.000 focos de incendio entonces
es grave pero cuando uno lo coloca en
perspectiva se observa que no es algo
solamente del gobierno bolsa
complemento a la información que da
gustado y es que el tamaño de esta zona
arrasada por los incendios es tan grande
como la extensión que tiene grecia que
es un país que pertenece a la unión
europea joana que carga política puede
llevarle a bolsonaro el no haber
manejado bien esta situación
medioambiental a nivel internacional es
decir ya veíamos usted lo mencionaba que
algunos presidentes como por ejemplo el
presidente macro no le han empezado a
cobrar factura pero esto puede tener
mayor alcance a nivel internacional o se
quedará en esa en ese cobro de factura
sólo en el g7 y por parte de francia
bueno son tiempos que se lo pregunta muy
interesante pienso que hay un debate
bastante álgido sobre el papel de los
actores internacionales en la política
doméstica a nivel general pero creo que
en este caso se hace bastante visible el
hecho de que a pesar de que bolsonaro
haya querido negar el hecho científico
fáctico y ambiental de que los incendios
se estaban expandiendo alrededor de
brasil
la comunidad internacional actores
estatales como bien ya lo has mencionado
el gobierno de francia y el gobierno de
canadá se han manifestado
en contra de esta situación al
mencionarlo como un problema de la
humanidad
bolsonaro ha dicho que la amazonía no es
patrimonio de la humanidad que es un
patrimonio de los países que tiene el
territorio en esa zona y que es una
falacia es decir que qué
que la amazonía es un patrimonio de la
humanidad pero estos factores
internacionales cada vez tienen más
fuerza de presión y le cobran le pasan
la factura como lo dijiste tú a nivel
local porque los movimientos sociales
que son fuertes en el brasil las
comunidades indígenas y los
ambientalistas empiezan a presionar en
la opinión pública nacional y pienso que
ahí se articulan tanto la opinión
pública internacional y la nacional para
exigir demandas y control al gobierno
porque el argumento de buen solar es
inválido en tanto que él dice que tanto
la pandemia como la
los incendios son fenómenos naturales
que él no controla pero un gobierno
también es juzgado por sus omisiones y
aquí estamos viendo que hay una gran
omisión y que si consideramos esto como
problema de la humanidad pues en
realidad es un asunto que no sólo le
atañe a bolsonaro sino que realmente le
atañe a todos los gobiernos de voto y
gustavo la misma pregunta pero a la
escala de brasil esto qué factura le
puede cobrar al presidente bolsonaro en
términos políticos
este tipo de manejo medioambiental ya
para cerrar este tema y qué tan
comprometido está el gobierno brasileño
y los mismos brasileños con estos temas
medioambientales hago la pregunta porque
leyendo un artículo del diario o'globo
de esa época cuando los incendios
estaban en su momento más álgido decían
que las personas que habían intentado
llegar a extinguir los incendios no
pudieron cumplir su labor por los
trámites burocráticos que ponía el
gobierno brasileño y retrasaron el
procedimiento cuatro meses para poder
empezar a extinguir los incendios
y bueno hay que ver siempre qué medio de
comunicación coloca la información sobre
todo porque hay responsabilidades
compartidas entre los gobiernos
provinciales y el gobierno nacional
desde el punto de vista local yo creo
que poco le afecta a bolsonaro la
situación de lo que ya ocurrió en la
amazonia es en el pantanal
específicamente porque son en momentos
determinados que cuando uno analiza en
la evaluación de la gente del elector en
relación al gobierno puntualmente en ese
caso en ese momento en particular sin
ninguna duda lo dan ya pero esto no le
retira la posibilidad no a bolsonaro al
gobierno que tenga que atender este tipo
de emergencias la posibilidad de
reelegirse o de elegirse si estamos
hablando de una elección como el caso
del próximo punto que serán las
elecciones municipales
la gente en general observa estas
situaciones con preocupación por
supuesto el elector mira más el bolsillo
que cualquier otra situación y esto lo
analizaremos seguramente en los próximos
puntos donde podemos evaluar porque el
gobierno evolucionar a pesar de todo
está con el mayor índice de popularidad
desde que comenzó su gobierno claro eso
ya nos nos lleva un poco a comenzar el
siguiente tema que tenemos en la agenda
que es este revés político que tuvo el
presidente bolsonaro y también la
izquierda el partido los trabajadores
del pp en esas elecciones regionales del
29 de noviembre donde 11 de los 13
candidatos que tenían respaldo del
presidente
bolsonaro sufrieron una derrota no
ganaron en alcaldías ni ni ni
gobernaciones estatales y el partido de
los trabajadores por primera vez desde
no va a gobernar ninguna de las
capitales de los estados brasileños esto
sin duda alguna muestra algún cambio de
percepción de los votantes de los
brasileños de la forma como quieren ser
gobernados castigan aa bolsonaro
castigan el pp como se puede cuál es la
lectura como se puede entender gustado
bueno en el caso particular bolsonaro
fue acertado en una estrategia electoral
porque él se retiró del partido que lo
llevó a la presidencia del ps él no
conformó un partido nuevo tanto que es
bolso el presidente bolsonaro sin
partido no tiene partido que lo
represente y él representa ningún
partido en las elecciones el apoyo a 13
candidatos para la intendencia municipal
es importante santiago aclarar que en
estas elecciones últimas no se votaron
gobernadores los gobernadores se votan
junto con las presidenciales en este
caso fueron municipales los intendentes
y los concejales que no se en francia-
cuál es el nombre que tiene son lo que
serían los legisladores de cada una de
las ciudades y en el caso particular de
los concejales él había apoyado a 45 de
los cuales la gran mayoría también
perdió y lo hizo a modo personal
nuevamente se impartido en el caso del
partido de los trabajadores además de
esta excelente información que
mencionaba en las capitales hoy el
partido de los trabajadores detenta el
35 por ciento del total de las
intendencias municipales son más
con 1500 ciudades y esto es uno de los
menores índices tanto del partido los
trabajadores como del apoyo que pudiera
haber recibido cualquier elector
cualquier candidato por parte de
bolsonaro la premiación fue para los
partidos del centro los más moderados
donde con mucha claridad se observa que
la gente está cansada esta grieta
electoral de la derecha y de la
izquierda y busca una posición un poco
más intermediaria gracias por esa
aclaración que usted hace gustado pasó a
preguntarle a johanna su percepción su
opinión sobre estos resultados de estas
elecciones como ya decíamos
complementando a algunos datos el pp que
en un momento tuvo un momento de auge
digámoslo así político en brasil
registro
en gobernar nueve capitales en el año
2004 cuando era el segundo mandato del
presidente luiz inácio del ex presidente
luiz inácio lula da silva su opinión
giovanna
pienso que estas elecciones municipales
siempre se podrían desestabilizar el
poder regional de de jake bolsonaro
claramente como lo mencionó gustavo aquí
fueron castigados estos partidos que
tradicionalmente habían estado en la
disputa o esta personalidad porque como
bien lo dijo gustavo bolsonaro no está
respaldado por una por un cuerpo
partidista sino que está
soportado en una fuerza más o en una
figura personal
pienso que este este castigo a la
selección este castigo a los a los
partidos tradicionales y este giro hacia
el centro muestra un poco el hartazgo
del pueblo brasilero respecto a estas
posiciones extremas que han venido
teniendo en una polarización permanente
al brasil pero es importante mencionar
también allí que el principal ganador de
estas elecciones fue el abstencionismo
la pandemia ha tenido que ver bastante
con estos resultados la pandemia ha sido
el tema transversal de estos temas que
hemos analizado en la agenda de este
programa ha gustado estos partidos de
centroderecha que usted mencionaba que
se han adjudicado algunos bastiones
importantes en términos políticos por
ejemplo la ciudad de sao paulo repite
con un alcalde de centroderecha de un
partido menos
hacia los extremos en río de janeiro
también de un giro de la ciudad de río
de janeiro y así otras capitales
importantes
recife victoria en el nordeste del país
qué peso tienen estos partidos de
centroderecha dado estos antecedentes
políticos de los últimos años
o cuando una realiza y es muy oportuno
el comentario de joana porque si uno
toma la cantidad de votos nulos blancos
y abstenciones ganaron las elecciones no
ganó ninguno de los candidatos sea el
sónar eso es ingreso importante declaró
porque en san pablo y en río de janeiro
las dos principales capitales del país
el candidato que ganó obtuvo menos votos
en porcentaje que los abstenciones nulos
y blancos entonces esto demuestra que la
gente primero está cansada de esta
situación obviamente la pandemia implicó
en una reducción de la cantidad de
electores que presentaron sus votos pero
de hecho en la colocación
específicamente del psdb el partido
socialdemócrata brasilero que fue el que
ganó en la ciudad de san pablo bruno
cobas era el anterior
intendente y consiguió la reelección
después de ir a un segundo turno
precisamente con un representante de la
izquierda que no representaba el partido
de los trabajadores
sino que era una persona que hace
tutoriales de cómo usurpar terrenos qué
es
guillerme módulos y esta colocación del
psdb demuestra que de mantenerse esta
situación en las próximas elecciones
presidenciales en el 2023 se puede
llegar 2022 perdón se puede llegar a
determinar que esta polarización entre
la derecha sin partido devolución ario
la izquierda de lula como uno de los
representantes únicos del partido de los
trabajadores puede tener una tercera
fuerza que si se ubica en el centro
suena como podemos interpretar esta no
sé si decirlo correctamente así caída
que ha tenido el pp en esta preferencia
de votos en estas elecciones muestra ya
como un ocaso de este partido después de
esos años de gloria cuando también la
izquierda dominaba varios países
latinoamericanos y brasil era uno de los
ejemplos pues de una izquierda que
fortaleció económicamente en cierto
momento el país como lo interpreta usted
estas figuras de lula da silva rousseff
que ya no están en la escena política
cuál es la lectura que usted hace
y contiene nuestra pregunta es
interesante y creo que tenemos que
mirarlo en una perspectiva regional y
global evidentemente hay un agotamiento
del pp que viene asociado a los
escándalos de corrupción
los impeachment que se realizaron a los
respectivos presidentes del pp y todo el
giro de la opinión pública que ha
llevado al resultado positivo de las
elecciones para jair bolsonaro sin
embargo al parecer estos dos extremos no
ha mostrado buenos resultados por eso
tal vez se explica la tendencia hacia el
centro de los votantes en el brasil pero
el agotamiento de esta izquierda
latinoamericana de esta izquierda en
brasil es sólo una muestra del
agotamiento de este modelo a lo largo
del continente esto tiene que ver
también con la crisis del chavismo en
venezuela
que se ha usado como una bandera
electoral a lo largo y ancho de
latinoamérica y más allá de
latinoamérica porque incluso trump lo
uso en las elecciones
para tenerlo como caballito de batalla
en un ambiente bastante polarizado pero
evidentemente aquí tenemos dos modelos
de crecimiento económico y de progreso
que se están disputando no suelen brasil
sino a lo largo de américa latina y creo
que esta discusión entre el agronegocio
y un desarrollo moderado y
conservacionista perdón es lo que está
sobre la mesa
gustavo quiero que pasemos al siguiente
tema de la agenda que son las
perspectivas económicas y lo que puede
venir para brasil en el 2021 y también
un poco que evaluemos cómo fue el 2020
en términos económicos sólo por dar
algunas cifras la economía de brasil
creció 7 o está creciendo 7.7 por ciento
para el tercer trimestre del 2020 es una
cifra bastante buena considerando la
situación en la que hemos estado a lo
largo de este año y la ocde destacó la
respuesta fiscal y monetaria que dio el
gobierno de brasil para poder enfrentar
esta crisis sanitaria y económica a
nivel mundial destacó cómo lo ha
manejado brasil su perspectiva de lo que
sucedió en el 2020
porque yo soy empresario en brasil
administro 53 compañías de diversos
sectores con lo cual puedo dar fe de lo
que ocurrió en diferentes sectores de la
economía en el medio de la pandemia al
principio la gente entendiendo que podía
ser un mes 2 el tema de la cuarentena o
el aislamiento social aquí en brasil
nunca llegó a ser cuarentena rígida
entendía que era necesario enfriar la
economía
preservando la salud pero después cuando
la pandemia continuaba a lo largo del
tiempo
bolsonaro que había de alguna manera
simplificado la situación porque le dio
muy poca atención decía que una gripe
que no había ningún riesgo en la salud
en la corte suprema le determina los
gobernadores y a los intendentes la
potestad de apertura o no de la economía
y ahí cuando nosotros observamos brasil
tiene una enorme ventaja que es los
indicadores económicos buenos por
ejemplo en este momento una tasa de
interés de referencia del 2% al año una
tasa de inflación en lo que va acumulado
el 2020
3.13 por ciento una enorme cantidad de
dólares ingresando por superávit en la
balanza comercial de 55.000 millones de
dólares eso explica porque el dólar que
llegó a estar a 5 reales con casi 80
centavos está en este momento en cinco
reales con cero siete centavos y por
otro lado la creación de empleo brasil
debe terminar a pesar de la pandemia con
creación positiva de empleos en este
momento está algo así como 180 mil
puestos de trabajo perdidos desde la
pandemia y debe terminar con algo
positivo cerca de 400 mil nuevos puestos
de trabajo en la bolsa otro ejemplo
llegó a estar en 120.000 puntos en la
pre pandemia bajó a 66 mil puntos y el
índice ibovespa hoy existen 114 mil 115
mil entonces cuando uno analiza el
impacto que el fm y le había destinado a
la proyección de decrecimiento del 9.1
por ciento al año y debe terminar
próximo al 44 y medio de manera que
cuando uno hace el balance el resultado
para brasil en el medio de la pandemia
en su economía es positivo
joana allí en la ciudad de colchester en
el reino unido- no sé usted qué piensa
de esta actitud del gobierno brasileño
tal vez por no generar pánico a nivel
económico porque sabía las consecuencias
que podría traer y darle mucha
importancia al tema de la pandemia fue
parte tal vez de la estrategia minimizar
como dice gustavo simplificar un poco
esta crisis sanitaria simplemente para
seguir generando confianza a nivel
económico y que otras cifras que en las
que no le está yendo muy bien como una
disminución en el índice de desarrollo
humano y el aumento de la pobreza pues
no se fueran por la borda como si le ha
pasado a otros países de la región
sí yo creo que cuando evaluamos la
situación económica hay que valorar tres
aspectos a parte del crecimiento
evidentemente el crecimiento es
importante pero debemos revisar incluso
que se ha reportado un decrecimiento del
pib del 1.5 por ciento del producto
interno bruto en el primer trimestre en
el brasil y la economía general ha caído
un 10 punto 98 por ciento en el segundo
trimestre entonces si bien ha habido un
crecimiento respecto a otros países de
la región debido a las medidas que se
han tomado en el manejo de la pandemia
se registra un desempleo significativo
que ronda el 13% 13.3 por ciento en la
región entonces allí hay que preguntarse
en términos de crecimiento y desarrollo
si solo estamos hablando de indicadores
generales de crecimiento
si estamos hablando también de
redistribución porque no olvidemos que
brasil tiene uno de los índices jimmy de
concentración de la riqueza más altos en
la región latinoamericano y este
indicador pues evidentemente no se ha
transformado de manera significativa
durante este gobierno esto creo que no
es una tendencia sólo en brasil sino de
los gobiernos que han tenido que decidir
entre priorizar entre la economía y
aspectos de salud y los dos aspectos
evidentemente son muy importantes sobre
todo en la región latinoamericana donde
la informalidad es creciente donde no
tenemos empleos formales y el efecto
económico de la pandemia ción más
visible y joane cuál es su perspectiva
para el año 2021 será un año complicado
para este país es importante hacer estas
evaluaciones de brasil porque es la
economía más importante de américa
latina es la más grande de suramérica y
pues en la medida que a ellos les vaya
bien pues eso puede ir
un poco a otros países particularmente a
los que están en el mercosur que tienen
unos acuerdos comerciales muy estrechos
con brasil y además que es un mercado
inmenso para el resto de los países para
venderle allí productos entonces como ve
usted la perspectiva
bueno en latinoamérica tendemos a
establecer dos potencias intermedias que
son méxico y brasil evidentemente el
papel de brasil es muy importante pero
esto pues depende de las medidas y las
reacciones que bolsonaro tenga ante la
presión internacional que está teniendo
porque creo que también ese desempeño
económico y el potencial desarrollo de
alianzas comerciales con el g7 estará
condicionado al desarrollo de medidas
reales para controlar la extensión de
los incendios entonces esta crisis
ambiental que pretende soberana e
independiente evidentemente está
afectando no sólo a la región sino la
situación ambiental del planeta de
manera que dependiendo de la respuesta
que él sea capaz de manejar y las
políticas que sea capaz de implementar
respecto a las demandas internacionales
este desempeño puede mejorar o reducirse
gustavo debo avanzar con el siguiente
tema y el último tema de la agenda que
es la gestión de la pandemia ya estamos
digámoslo así en un segundo capítulo que
es la llegada de las vacunas y los
planes de vacunación la negociación con
las farmacéuticas ya podemos dar por
cerrado ese primer capítulo de
confinamiento la sorpresa que nos llegó
esta pandemia a todos los rincones y se
puede hacer una evaluación y
particularmente brasil el presidente
bolsonaro ha sido muy criticado por la
forma como manejó la pandemia es el
segundo país con la mayor cantidad de
casos cuál es la evaluación que usted
hace
bueno todo es relativo y cuando uno
analiza la situación recuerdo al
principio de la pandemia ocho y media de
la noche todos los días había
cacerolazos contra el presidente
bolsonaro que mencionaba que había que
seguir trabajando que la gente tenía que
salir a la calle a producir y la clase
media que lo había votado sobre todo le
había retirado un apoyo electoral
importante que eran los que precisamente
salían a las casas de las calles con las
cacerolas y a los balcones el gobierno
tomó una actitud muy interesante que es
la ayuda social a aquellos que como muy
bien decía joana están en la
informalidad eran en personas que
trabajaban
de repente vendiendo café o tortas en la
puerta de una fábrica y con eso llevaba
renta a su domicilio esta gente que
fueron 54 millones de personas
consiguieron no solamente una
sobrevivencia importante a lo largo de
la pandemia sino que esta gestión
permitió que 15 millones de brasileros
crezca en función de las necesidades
sociales o sea 15 millones de obras y 2
salieron de la línea extrema de pobreza
conforme iba aumentando la cantidad de
días de la pandemia esta gente que
reclamaba contra bolsonaro dejó de
hacerlo porque si no salía a trabajar no
tenía recursos y hoy esto es lo que
permite de alguna manera mostrar que el
índice de aprobación de bolsonaro en su
persona y de la imagen del gobierno esté
por arriba de inclusive son los
indicadores de principios de su gestión
allá por el año 2019 inicio de 2019
claramente el problema más allá no es
solamente lo que bolsonaro dice sino
como lo dice lo mejor que hubiera pasado
por sanar o quedarse quieto porque como
la corte le había sacado la potestad
para poder determinar en la ampliación o
la disminución del aislamiento todo
hubiera sido responsabilidad favorable o
no de los gobernadores y de los
intendentes pero bolsonaro evolucionaron
claro y joana su opinión su balance
sobre el manejo de la pandemia o sobre
sí sobre el manejo de la pandemia bueno
pues en este momento según los datos
disponibles en la universidad de johns
hopkins que es uno de los de las bases
de datos más confiables para el registro
y seguimiento de la pandemia brasil
ocupa el tercer lugar en contagios
alrededor del mundo con alrededor de 7
millones de infecciones y 183 mil
muertes no es una cifra baja estamos
hablando de alrededor del 10 por ciento
de las infecciones a nivel mundial
creo que es la negación del hecho de la
existencia de la pandemia ha sido
irresponsable por parte de bolsonaro
esto también sucedió con otros gobiernos
inicialmente vimos en la reino unida
aquí también este discurso de hardin
munitis una falta de regulación en la
atención de la pandemia que terminó que
terminó pasando factura porque agua
salió el sistema de salud entonces hay
ciertamente hay un dilema entre salud y
economía pero la negación de los hechos
respecto a los incendios la negación de
la pandemia misma y el argumento de que
la naturaleza se regula por si sordos
son irresponsables por parte de un
gobernante porque un gobernante debe
cumplir y si no debe ser juzgado por
omisión en este caso es lo que le está
sucediendo a bolsonaro ya el pp lo ha
llamado juicio político para responder
por el manejo de la pandemia del
creciente
el número de infecciones y el número
creciente de casos fatales pues hay
muchas personas que están de acuerdo con
estas políticas adelante gustavo me
quedan pocos segundos adelante rapidito
hay que tomarlo en perspectiva porque
brasil tiene 212 millones de personas
cuando uno analiza por millón de
habitantes en contagios y en fallecidos
brasil y está número 19 en fallecidos en
el mundo y 33 en contagios de manera que
no fue tan mal manteniendo la economía
si uno hace el análisis por ejemplo con
argentina destruyeron la economía y
tienen más cantidad de contagios y de
muertos por millón de habitantes pues se
quedan las conclusiones los puntos de
vista de nuestros invitados sobre este
tema estos cuatro temas que teníamos en
la agenda para este especial del debate
de france 24 a johanna y ha gustado
muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros habernos acompañado y haber
compartido con nosotros sus opiniones a
ustedes muchas gracias por la sintonía
sigan con la programación de france 24
[Música]